Now, recall,
the concept of Epsilon Photography.
Something by now,
you should be familiar with,
because you did an assignment of trying
to capture a sequence of pictures.
Epsilon Photography aims to capture
sequence of different pictures,
where basically, we're changing one
parameter by just a minute amount.
Very small Epsilon amount to capture
the variations in a scene, and
then, of course, fuse the different
pictures together, to create
a richer representation that captures
a scene, and variety of conditions.
And that could be used to synthesize
novel pictures, taking multiple captures
of the single scene, or the single
image to generate a newer image.
We looked at a variety of examples.
We can actually, change the exposure.
If you recall, this was an example
of what we did to create HDR images.
So, by fusing the three different
exposures of this image,
we were able to generate an HDR image.
Another example could be,
the viewpoint, right?
Where we change the camera parameters
by changing the viewpoint, and
then fusing them together,
we can create a panorama.
Many other examples of this exist.
Here is an example of being able
to capture a focus stack, and
then being able to generate a new image
that basically has no focus variations,
or, of course, sometimes we can then
controllrably change the variation.
But in Epsilon Photography,
the goal was to be able to capture
all of those images, and in fact,
actually capture multiple images.
Then those multiple images could be
then used to generate a newer image, or
perhaps, you want a controllable image
that could be generated on the fly.
Now, remember, part pipeline for
Computational Photography.
We want to capture a 3D scene,
which is illuminated,
the optics focus a light onto a sensor.
We can process the images to generate
a new output display for a user.
If you recall this from our earlier
lectures, basically this was kind of
showcased in the following manner,
we had a 3D scene, we can illuminate
the scene with the computer controlled
projector, a controllable light source.
And of course, we can control the light
source entirely, or also the parts of it
by creating some sort of,
a Modular Controllable Aperture.
Remember, again,
we have looked at this example
in the previous lecture when we talked
about projector camera systems.
Another option, also was to
create a camera, and of course,
we would, knew how to do cameras.
We learned all there is to, about
the updates and the pinhole aspect of
a camera, but we can also start thinking
that now I can put some sort of,
a Controllable Aperture
in front of this,
that not only controls the amount
of light that goes in.
But also, which parts of the sensor
will be lit based on which parts I
either restrict or open.
So, that's the basic pipeline
that we have looked at.
We've looked up
projector camera systems.
We have looked at how illumination
source with a camera can be used to
extract, and
generate a newer types of images.
We have looked at the camera, but
we haven't actually looked at how
to control different aspects of it,
in this way, except,
in a few examples like the dual
photography example that we looked at.